hi everyone my name is Heinrich and
welcome to firm learning thank you for
being back and watching this video today
with this channel I want to help you to
be successful in the first years of your
career and as you know one of the things
that will be crucial in many roads and
business will be PowerPoint today I'm
talking about one topic and PowerPoint
that I see many people do wrong and this
is using smart arts do you use smart at
the PowerPoint the truth is that in a
professional presentation you just
should not use smart arts in your
PowerPoint presentations in this video
I'm going to tell you why why you should
not use smarts and some substitutes some
other things that you can use to achieve
very similar effects compared to using
smarts and I will also tell you why it's
much better to do these things instead
of other things if you would like to
receive more videos like that please
press the subscribe button and if you
like this video please also press the
like button all of this will have other
people to find this content and if
you're really serious to improve how you
create your presentations in a
professional manner and if you would
like to learn how top strategy
consulting firms like BCG or Bain
actually create their PowerPoint
presentations I created a full
multi-hour course on that with over
10,000 students currently taking it you
can read the reviews of other students
to get an understanding whether this is
something that might interest you would
might actually behave for the beneficial
to you so let's start with what smart
arts actually are according to the
office support page smarts are something
that you can use to quickly and easily
make a visual representation of your
information you can choose among many
different layouts to efficiently or
effectively communicate your message or
idea
so basically small arts are something
that Microsoft and ended with the
intention to help you to quickly and
easily visualize your information so
let's look at a few examples just that
you get an idea what I'm talking about
so smarter too confined here under
insert and then smart arts and then your
whole menu of different things opens up
and on first side and looks quite
helpful and interesting right
different examples of things you can use
of forms and shades that might be indeed
helpful in order to visualize your ideas
so that's just open a few for instance
something like this little boxes with
text apparently you could put photos in
here as well it's smaller maybe another
one something like this looks
interesting or even another example
maybe on a matrix such an assembly of
different squares where you can also put
X in it so yes I agree on first sight
that looks interesting in headphone and
actually SmartArt I personally see being
used quite frequently in amateur
presentations and people who are not
really using PowerPoint frequently or
not using PowerPoint in any professional
capacity in these kind of presentations
I see smart arts frequently used but now
it might surprise you that in
professional presentations and
presentations that are being done in big
large bunch of companies and especially
by large strategy consulting firms small
ads are literally never used people just
do not use smart arts in this video I'd
like to go over the advantages and may
need the disadvantages of using smart
arts to help you understand why people
actually don't use smart UPS and why
just really bear to use them and I will
also show you a few alternatives of what
you actually can do in order to do very
similar things pretty much get the same
results without actually using smart
arts in PowerPoint so now let's look
into something that you will frequently
use in management presentations and this
is some visualization of a process chart
so here I now created kind of a basic
template about how this could look like
so you see now a collection of different
steps steps one step two step three step
four Step five it's process so these
steps are supposed to happen one after
each other and now you'd like to
visualize it and also give details on
the individual steps with some kind of
hierarchy of bullet points and this is
really a typical chart that you would
use in concise
my six years at McKinsey I used charts
like that many many times appropriated
over a hundred of pages that look more
or less like this of course without some
variations how many steps are included
or how exactly it is shown but pretty
much pages like that are very commonly
used at consulting and from the style
you would think that this is something
that you probably could do really well
with a smart I mean after all smarts are
exactly supposed to help you do things
like that had to create charts like that
but you can easily display and visualize
your information right so well let's try
to create a page like that or somehow
similar like that in a smart so first we
need to choose a suitable design so
let's go into smarts and here you see
that they actually have a whole section
of how to visualize processes so indeed
smarts apparently are exactly supposed
to help you to visualize process like
that and from my perspective now pitch
shows a very basic form may be a process
may be a process chart where at the top
you see the different steps and then you
have some text below to describe them
but now here if we go over the designs
actually most of the designs are
supposed to look much more fancy much
more complicated where there are lots of
different shapes and relationships but
such a very basic shape where you just
have a header and then text to describe
it it's not really included here
probably the closest thing that you can
find is this one where you have a header
and giving a title of the different
steps and then some space to explain
them and this is something first thing
that I see a lot when looking at smarts
that their designs that they have are
often not very practical they're much
more playful than actually useful
because most of the time charts like
that are not really helpful in used but
you need more simpler things but then
you aren't even able to do in the smart
but let's now pick this design because
apparently this is what Microsoft things
should use when you create such a
process approach where you have
different steps and then text explaining
the details on the step so first of all
let's try to do some basic formatting on
it let's try to set a font size of
fourteen and the first thing that you
notice when I change the font size that
pretty much the whole dimension of all
these different objects change so
usually you would expect that if you
change the font size pretty much
everything stays the same or need two
font size changes but here it's not the
case and you will not see it that this
is one of the reasons why it's pretty
difficult to actually work with small
dots because one little change with one
little part of the smart very frequently
changes the whole smart just really
makes it difficult in getting the exact
result that you want but let's continue
working know we had not three steps as
we see here but actually five steps so
let's now include additional steps now
we have the five steps here let's now
try to drag it in a way that the whole
page is covered so that you don't waste
space and let's not try to use similar
text as we had on our example page no I
mean basic people like me good thing
that you might be able to just copy that
in here but for whatever reason that
just doesn't really seem to work right
so if I call this first aspect now
please tell me for what reason is this
now smaller than the rest of us if you
look here into the hierarchy of bullets
it looks exactly the way that here but
for whatever reason all the smart
reduced the font size so now you can go
back and put it back to 14 but I think
you get the idea let's not just imagine
that you would have had all the text
here that we wanted but now what you can
see is that the design is it's used here
it's not very efficiently using the
space right because you see lots of
playing space so what we actually would
need to do now especially if we compare
it with this diagram where
I could not easy different lots of text
we need to make these little boxes a bit
larger in order to actually make create
more space so usually I would now
highlight all the boxes and then try to
direct them a bit larger in a way that
then I have more space and now we see it
again and I'll direct the boxes a bit
larger and for whatever reason now this
upper part is now much smaller and looks
much different it's more I could
highlight from these because also this
is now a super large surface given that
it's covered by the actual Texas right
so why would you need that so let's not
make it smaller and that okay you can
see here that it's automatically I'm not
holding any keys trying to make the
upper part smaller as well so if I
release now it looks like this which of
course doesn't make sense to I go back
so at em you know what do I need to do
in order to make these things smaller if
I not handle one it don't looks like
this so just extremely difficult not to
get it in a way that I want to maybe now
I can try to shift all of them a bit up
and now if I do that maybe I have a bit
more luck but you see that it just it's
3me difficult to run with that right
okay but now we can tell us if that
maybe we just chose the wrong smart
maybe there's another smart type and
it's actually much easier to use let's
go back into process and I mean the one
thing that I saw a bit earlier that
probably would help me to get such an
effect is one of these process bars
right so let's try them out this now
would be an alternative but you can put
some text under it so now again let's
try to fill it with some basic text now
we can spread it out like this you know
one thing you'll be notice so let's just
say we only want to keep it it it step
three is that these are far too large
right so now the process
our safe just covers a significant
portion of the page but now what do we
need to do in order to actually make it
smaller I try to grab this and release
this but it just doesn't do anything now
I can try to grab all these three at the
same time but it's still not happening
now if I want to actually smaller it
this way now I'm excite this right if I
will make it larger it looks like this I
mean you see it's just a huge pain to
work with these kind of elements I hope
I convinced you by now
which is why in professional contexts
they're just not being used it just
extremely difficult to get the results
that you want and in most cases you are
much faster in order to create designs
like that by yourself
so let's try to replicate this page that
just that you see how it actually works
to give you the confidence that you
could do that much faster yourself with
all these kinds of small ads so let's
first without using the smart section
create the basic shapes and now we want
such a process I can like this and now
it's formatted a bit in a basic way
typically we go for such a clean flat
design like this now of course what you
can do is just copy it a couple of times
and there's a little shortcut that no I
will insert in the screen just for you
to see how it actually works
but now this way you can directly copy
the very same element different times
right now we can distribute it
horizontally and this already looks
quite decent I'd say so let's see step
one of course this is now also supposed
to be in Mac this in na VI so that's
just for the sake of time insert the
text boxes here of course you can also
copy it in the same way we align this
here to left and distribute it it's all
nice and evenly spread out and of course
you you will know how to insert
such a line okay do some basic
formatting of the line let's put it at
one point wait and we make it dot it so
this way it's all lined in proper way
and now we have a chart that more legs
looks like this probably this is a bit
too close to the bullets on the right so
we shift them over a bit more to the
left now I have a properly nice and fine
a process chart just the way we wanted
to of course sometimes you need a bit
more complex shapes that might not
directly come out of PowerPoint out of
the box if you look here in the shapes
are and sometimes you might be inclined
to see that actually is things like that
exist in the SmartArt section so you
might ask yourself but how can I
actually create these more complex
shapes without using smart arts so let's
try that out let's create a new page
here I'm deleting all of this and let's
for instance say what looks maybe a bit
more fancy for instance these circuits
with different cut lines and threw it at
them so for instance if the glasses
empty you who are half full or
completely full or whatever this is
supposed to symbolize right now this is
supposed to look like and interestingly
enough here now you can actually just
make it bigger but let's imagine we want
to create circles like that how do you
want to do that without using smarts
because we all know that something
exactly like that just doesn't exist
here in the same shape section so let's
delete that and you always need to
realize that these more complex shapes
are usually created out of more basic
shapes like circuits so if we create a
circle here we can format it now we can
probably easily create the version in
which the circle was full probably it
looks something like that let's give it
another color and now we can
centered and properly now this is
something like the circuit that we saw
earlier but now what do we need to do in
order to cut it in half for instance to
make this inner part appear in half and
here is now a section that's really
handy and useful in PowerPoint that
maybe you already know or maybe not and
this is called merge shapes and with
merge shapes you can create some more
complex shape forms for your use in
PowerPoint because now what actually we
need is to kind of cut out the upper
half of the circle or some portion of
the circle in order to create a look
where this circle is not whole but
actually divided into different parts
and we can do that by subtracting
another form from the circle form so
let's not just create a second form you
know a square which only purpose it is
to subtract something from this lower
form now you see that I aligned through
the way that this cuts the circle in
half or what cuts a circle in half and
now I need to select these two shapes
for the subtract function of course it's
always important which shape gets
subtracted from its shape so lets me do
it the wrong way so let me first select
this shape and then second this shape if
I now go into shape format I'm going to
merge shapes and then go into subtract
now the circle is subtracted from this
rectangle but this is of course not what
we want we first need to be selecting
the form from which something is to be
subtracted and then second we select the
form which is being subtracted and if
you do it this way and if you merge
shape and then subtract then you get a
half circle just the way that you want
it pretty much so let's draw inserted
here how do you need the other shape
this is exactly what you want and now of
course if you want to do it in a way
that it's not cutting it in half but
maybe even a bit more than in half you
can just put it like this and then you
shape format merge and substrate to not
get this even smaller sub part of the
circle that you might want to raise
out here and with this function of
merging subtracting and other operations
that you have with the shapes you can
create very complex forms if you want
and just to go over that what do these
different things do here you can go into
Union which gives you here the very same
shape you can go into combine where it
subtracts the upper part but still
leaves you with the lower part you can
go with fragment which now kind of gives
you the sub parts of all these different
shapes and you can go subtract we
already did but intersect would give you
only the part that's actually covered by
both shapes so exactly this form so I
hope you that you can see that the
things that you could create the things
that you can do a pretty much limitless
and do create really complex shapes here
so to sum up in professional context
smart arts are just not being used very
often if you do use them at least in a
strategy consulting environment you will
be told by your project leader by your
partner that please you do not use mod
arts because it just lets you look
unprofessional even if you by somehow
tweaking your turn spending lots of time
you might manage to get a smaller look
the way that you want and the easiest
and most forward way for my perspective
is just to avoid that and directly
create the shapes the graphics that you
want to use manually by combining the
different sub elements uh form such
shapes that you can create here just in
a way that you want to then you can
create perfectly professionally looking
slides that process the ER diagrams and
the way that we did it and also by
combining different forms using the
merge shapes functionality you can also
create more complex forms which might
not be existed in PowerPoint out of the
box so thank you for watching I hope all
of that make sense to you so let me know
what do you think do you use smart arts
in your PowerPoint presentations did I
actually convince you to not use them
anymore if not where I guess that's also
been at opinion just let me know what
your thoughts are and I'm also happy to
answer any comments you might have again
please
like button below if you took any value
out of this video and if you would like
to stay up to date with more content
like that on how to create consulting
style PowerPoint presentations please
subscribe and if you're really serious
about learning all of this look into the
video description there you'll find a
link to an online course that I created
that ends the teaching you the end to
end process our top strategy consulting
firms create their PowerPoint
presentations all the best to you this
is highly from firm learning and thank
you very much for watching